hé gamin, je suis un peu jeune pour un
barman, tu n'es pas un peu vieux pour le
bal de promo, n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
tout ici pourquoi la carte un
plus gros trésor qui n'a jamais été trouvé
cinq milliards facile mais c'est juste une histoire que
je t'en supplie  pour différer
[Musique] il
y a 500 ans,
ma famille a trouvé la plus grande fortune du monde
puis a été trahie
les gens ont tout cherché en
vain tous les
deux tu tournes tes clés dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre en
même temps
merci beaucoup tu as failli me faire tuer [ __ ]
pourquoi salir et bien ça  avait 50 50 donc j'ai
fait une supposition claire
mais le voyage n'était pas seulement une question d'or
c'était quelque chose de beaucoup plus précieux cette
croix a une histoire très tragique tellement de
sang
je suis presque sûr qu'il menace juste de
me tuer,
ne te fais pas attraper
allaient juste me laisser là-bas,
quelqu'un devait obtenir la croix,
ton frère croyait qu'il y avait un
dernier morceau,
et bien, tu sais, mon frère a dit que
tu n'avais aucune idée avec qui tu avais collaboré avec
quoi d'autre, tu ne me dis pas que le
vainqueur
se gâte,
comment vont-ils  je vais les sortir d'ici
euh
[Musique]
hé pose-les les garçons, c'est quoi
ce truc sur ton visage ouais la
puberté approche à grands pas gamin
tu peux grandir toi-même